[Music]
this is what Disney Princesses would
look like at your high school
we've been watching Disney Princess
movies since we were kids
every little girl and boy wish they
could be part of this magical universe
and meet the love of their lives but
what if our favorite princesses were
part of our world
here come the new girls in town get
ready to meet them because they are
going to your high school just wait
until you see Rapunzel and Eugene
walking to class together they'll win
the prize for the cutest couple at the
end of the school year if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a big thumbs up this is what Disney
Princesses would look like at your high
school Elsa the princess had to learn
how to control her secret power during
her teenage years and now we know what
she did during all this time she was not
locked in her room she was in high
school studying to be a better Queen
tumblr artist pansy Ella portrayed her
as a grown-up young woman ready to
change the world now a senior at the
school Elsa is president of the student
council she is already a leader trying
to make the school a better place for
everyone the ice queen is the woman all
the girls want to be and all the guys
want to date but she doesn't need a man
you can't go to prom with a guy he just
met and rumor says she was seen holding
hands with a girl we know that people
keep gossiping in high school just let
it go and let her be happy with whoever
she wants Anna if there is one girl who
is happy to go to school
it is Elsa's sister Anna after being in
a castle alone for too long the princess
couldn't wait to see her sister again
and make tons of friends she finally
found someone to help her build the
snowman tumblr artist puns yellow was
inspired by her colorful personality
when he imagined her in high school Anna
is part of every artistic Club in the
school because she wants to meet as many
people as possible but there is one
thing she loves even more boys she can't
keep herself from falling in love with a
new guy every week fortunately her big
sister is here to keep an eye on her and
it deserves better than any high school
boy as long as the two sisters stayed
together Anna knows she already has all
the love she needs Pocahontas Anusha
Syed is another illustrate
who loves Disney Princesses not only did
she draw pictures of our favorite
characters but she thought about what
they would be doing in school to the
Native American princess loves hiking
kayaking and cliff diving during the
weekend she's a total adrenaline junkie
but she is still able to sit at a desk
all day when she goes back to high
school
she works hard to be accepted in
linguistics in college
Pocahontas wants to work as a cultural
advisor in the film industry her goal is
to make sure that movies respect other
cultures and represent them in the best
way wouldn't it be great to tell the
story of a Native American woman as seen
by Pocahontas herself a friend of a
friend told us she's not dating John
Smith anymore
what is her version of the story Belle
illustrator Anisha Syed imagined an
alternative story for Belle too we all
know the Beauty loves reading books but
she was even more impressed when she
found out about movies and TV shows the
princess can't stop watching her
favorite series until 4:00 in the
morning and she's a fan as you can see
from her skirt and her lunchbox
fortunately she still has time to do her
homework even though she is always
sitting in front of a TV we all know
that kind of friend who gets good grades
even though they are not working as much
as we are
but Belle has one weakness she keeps
falling in love with the bad boy the
bookworm believes she is going to be
able to make him change but we all know
that men always stay the same or maybe
she will prove that we were all wrong
ilan me there are so many people at the
school that we don't know all of them
and sometimes you've been in the same
class with someone for five years
and you don't even know their name this
kind of person is along me as hi young
86 designed her on deviantART even
though she will grow up to be a
beautiful confident woman
the princess is really shy in high
school she would rather be watching
movies on a Friday night than partying
with all the other teenagers and there
is nothing wrong with that alone we
doesn't care about what other students
think she has her own style and she
loves the freedom of doing whatever she
wants the princess dreams of becoming a
writer so she can create a world where
everything is possible for her Aurora
here is another princess drew by hayoung
86 on deviantART Aurora is an artist who
keeps daydreaming all day during class
she's not listening to the teacher
because
all she can think about is that handsome
celebrity she once met in her dream
every girl has the right to fantasize
about guys her notebooks are full of
drawings of Aurora and her prints
together but there is another thing this
girl loves her old spinning wheel she
spends all evening using it and goes to
bed at 2:00 in the morning
this is the reason why she is late in
class Aurora is always over sleeping but
there was one thing she still hasn't
figured out yet which dress she could
make for prom
does she look more beautiful in a blue
dress or a pink dress don't be shy to
tell us what you think in the comments
your friend needs advice Tiana
Anisha Syed imagined many alternative
lives for Disney Princesses including
Tiana this girl is working as a waitress
in a restaurant during the weekend while
she is studying in high school during
the week she knows that she needs to
work hard to succeed and that's why she
is starting now her dream is to become
an entrepreneur and open the Tiana's
palace cafe and she believes it is going
to be really popular with the family
recipes bayonets and jazz shows Tiana
knows that sky is the limit
so she hopes that we will one day find
her restaurant all over the country but
for now let's hope that she also finds
time to live a teenage love Tiana knows
how to see inner beauty and there was a
student who would really be happy if she
noticed him
Mulan Milan is another princess who
inspired a new society and once again
she wants to be one of the boys Mulan
wants to join the military school after
high school but people don't take her
seriously because she is a girl
fortunately a gym trainer believes in
this courageous woman and wants to help
her get in shape Mulan knows that one
day she will prove that she can be
stronger than any other man if a man can
do it a woman can do it better the
future cadet hopes that one day more
doors will be open to women who want to
work in the military and if they don't
give her a place at that school she is
going to take that place she deserves if
you ever make fun of people running like
a girl in gym class just watch her go
and you'll never say that again Merida
it seems like tumblr pansy Ella had a
lot of imagination because here's
another of her drawing compared to many
other girls in high school Merida is not
a damsel in distress she knows what she
wants and she does what it takes to
that's why she is a part of the archery
club she goes straight to the point but
there is something that is still too
difficult for her and her father wants
her to study medicine after high school
but Merida wants to become a
professional Archer the princess wants
to take control of her own destiny and
she won't let anybody stop her
she doesn't care about money Merida
knows that what matters is finding a job
that makes her happy Jane she will later
marry the king of the jungle so this
makes her a queen this is what
illustrator Anisha Syed thought to when
she designed this character Jane loves
nature so much that she wants to become
a scientific illustrator during the
lunch break she is always outside of the
high school drawing all the little
creatures she can seem and the best time
of the year is when she goes to the zoo
with her classmates Jane hopes she will
one day be old enough to assist her
father in his research on African
gorillas she doesn't think that she is
one day going to meet the man of her
dreams among these apes finding a
passion is often the best way to find
love but stop talking about boys Jane
knows that it is important to focus on
school now so she can later get her
college degree Cinderella the Princess
inspired deviant-art artist hye-young 86
to create another character Cinderella
liked to wear practical clothes because
she knew that brain is more important
than looks she was a good student who
always seems to come home before
midnight but secretly the princess
wanted to be a bad girl and party like
all the other kids well anyone save her
from this life full of homework and
house chores just wait until prom to see
her in a beautiful blue dress the
student who was not popular at all
suddenly became the one to catch the eye
of the most handsome guy in school
they danced all night long and she
thought that she had found the love of
her life but now he won't answer her
text messages and claims that he doesn't
even know her name
high school boys Jasmine the Arabia
princess was the inspiration of another
drawing from Anisha Syed this time the
young woman is not showing her belly but
is wearing a hijab instead she is a
Muslim just like many other girls from
her country but we don't care what's on
her head what matters is what's in it
Jasmine wants to become a travel blogger
her dream is to explore the world and
immerse herself in different cultures
she already travelled a lot with her
boyfriend Aladdin
wishes to visit every country in the
world other things she is passionate
about our animals Jasmine has five cats
and hopes that she will have even more
in the future but for now she
understands that she has to stay in
place at her desk so she can later fly
all around the world Snow White the
princess couldn't resist the temptation
and became a fashion blogger or at least
this is what illustrator Anusha Syed
things
her stepmother feared that she would
become more beautiful than her and she
was right to think so Snow White is now
a professional Instagram erm she is
never seen without her iPhone and she
keeps taking selfies all the time unlike
many other models she doesn't want to
get a tan and believes that natural
beauty is what makes you look the best
the princess is so obsessed by social
media that she uses hashtags in her
exams in English class if you are
wondering who is the fairest of them all
just look at her Instagram account she
is the one who has the most followers in
high school but don't say that to her
stepmother or she might confiscate her
cellphone Ariel look at Ariel as pawns
yella imagined her this girl is so
beautiful with all her curves forget
about the thigh gap did you know that if
your thighs touch you're one step closer
to becoming a mermaid unfortunately the
princess isn't so confident Ursula
encouraged her to stop going to the glee
club so she could go to the gym and lose
weight and she is doing all this for a
guy she met once after she sang in her
school's musical play but Ursula knows
that Eric loves curvy girls that's why
she wants to get rid of the competition
and seduce him Ariel should know that no
girl should ever change to please a man
if he doesn't love you as you are he
won't love you in any other way
anyway the best thing to love is Pizza
Pizza will always be there for you
Rapunzel pansy Ella imagined Rapunzel as
one of the most beautiful girls in high
school but sorry guys she is already
taken the princess is dating Eugene also
known as Flynn Rider and when you see
them together you know this is
relationshipgoals
Rapunzel had a strict mother who
wouldn't let her go out she was
home-schooled and barely even knew what
a man was but then the nice girl
accidentally met a handsome bad boy and
the two have been dating each other
since that day when they walked down the
hallways other students wish they could
live the same love story too
school is the perfect time to fall in
love and these two are certainly
enjoying that moment if only we could
meet the love of our lives in high
school too it would be a true fairy tale
do you agree with all these alternative
stories of what Disney Princesses would
look like at your high school tell us in
the comments down below and what you
imagined it would be like if you liked
this video don't forget to give it a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more and if you can't get enough of
Disney Princesses just watch 10
alternate stories of Disney Princesses
in other countries thanks for watching
[Music]